heures bien christian estrosi vous êtes
député ump des alpes-maritimes et
rapporteur du projet de loi sarkozy sur
la sécurité intérieure et vous êtes en
plus de ça un ami je crois qu'on peut
lire de la sarkozie on peut le dire on
peut le dire la lèze bruno comme il est
allé jeter raclot pas c'est parce qu'il
est mieux qu avec toi alors votre livre
christian estrosi publié rocher en 2001
qui s'appelle insécurité sauver la
république vous montre quand même
partisan de la manière forte bien le
dire non il n'est pas question pour nous
de rétablir aujourd'hui un ordre moral
prêt et je crois que ce qui s'est passé
au printemps dernier en france
et quand même un signal très fort c'est
le pacte républicain tout entier qui est
menacé depuis maintenant deux trois
quatre cinq ans avec la montée de cette
violence et de cette délinquance qui
ressenti par les françaises et les
français comme un un vrai phénomène de
détresse de privation de liberté une
quelquefois et c'est vrai que j'ai
travaillé j'ai écrit j'ai réfléchi
dernier conakry l'asie comme dirait un
record à 6 il ne parle que de république
thierry ardisson la république c'est
quand même ce que nous avons de plus
cher et l'avertissement que nous avons
reçus des françaises et français au
printemps dernier quand même fort c'est
à dire que si nous ne savons pas
répondre aux défis qui nous a été lancé
nous aurons des lendemains difficiles
nous nous réveillerons dans un climat de
cauchemar alors je crois que le défi que
nous sommes en train de relever
aujourd'hui est le seul qui apporte une
véritable espérance aux plus faibles aux
plus défavorisés aux plus démunis qui
comme toujours dans notre société sont
les plus exposés ouais les plus démunis
je sais pas les
les lois qui sont passés aujourd'hui
grâce à monsieur sarkozy
je crois que justement a atteint les
plus démunis pas forcément les
travailleurs qui habitent dans les cités
mais aussi les jeunes qui habitent ça
fait un moment qu'on est exclu que la
politique depuis un certain nombre
d'années elle n'est pas dirigée pour que
les jeunes puissent trouver vraiment une
solution et pouvoir s'intégrer à la
société
donc quand on voit qu'il ya plus de
solution on utilise la répression un mot
aujourd'hui les lois sarkozy alors que
ça fait un moment que les gens sont
conscients quand même quand bon lui il
se passe des problèmes que tous les
jeunes n'ont pas de boulot que l'avenir
pour eux n'est pas rose tous les jours
donc
eh ben il reste aujourd'hui à construire
des prisons plutôt que des écoles bien
mais ça fait un moment qu'il ya un
moment il ya ya ya un bon nombre de
personnes qui s'en plaignent de ça ça
fait un moment que tout le monde s'en
plaint
et c'est le moment d'apporter une
réponse qui sont les prisons et une
réponse je veux dire d'abord sans tabou
parce que trop longtemps n'a été enfermé
dans cette espèce de politiquement
correct où que ce soit dans des
émissions taxer les intelligents à vous
excuser les bouts c'est sûr que ce soit
un mais que ce soit les hommes
politiques eux mêmes qui sont tous
fautifs de gauche comme de droite de ne
pas avoir apporté les réponses adaptées
nous arrivons à la situation à laquelle
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui donc
c'est vrai on n'a rien fait on n'a
apporté aucune réponse
joris alors je vous la réponse est là
justement à ça alors mais non mais tu as
d'ailleurs que les poules james kool
shen et christian estrosi on va voir on
va voir on va passer en revue en vitesse
mais ça va vous donner l'occasion de
s'exprimer en tous les cas
christian estrosi on va passer en revue
la loi sarkozy alors la mendicité par
exemple vous voulez mettre des amendes
aux mendiants mais s'il na qui les
mendiants c'est qu'il n'a pas d'argent
pour payer les amendes
à aucun moment il ne s'agit de toucher
aux mendiants
au contraire nous souhaitons par
d'autres dispositions que ce soit le
ministre de la ville jean louis borloo
que ce soit françois fillon par le
contrat d'intégration
nous avons d'autres réponses apportées à
tout ça il s'agit de s'attaquer à ceux
qui exploitent la mendicité d'autrui
c'est à dire à ceux qui profitent des
mendiants avec deux incriminations qui
sont très fortes
d'abord
la mendicité en bande de manière
agressive et pour toujours s'est demandé
si tu essaies de la quête
oui c'est du racket j'avais utilisé le
terme exact mais vous savez comment se
passent les choses aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
arpente un trottoir et qu'on est agressé
par une bande dite de mendiants et qui
sont mes près tout mettre en oeuvre pour
vous extorquer des fonds
ça s'appelle de la mendicité en bande
agressive c'est cette incrimination ça
n'est pas une attaque aux mendiants
je peux vous dire que cette que cette
forme d'agressivité est monté de 35%
cours des cinq dernières années
je peux vous parler aussi de la
mendicité à l'aide d'animaux dangereux
et où des enfants bien sûr des pires
ennemis ils sont des réalités
1 en tout cas tout cela nous le faisons
sans excès et sans outrance simplement
en cherchant à répondre de manière
pragmatique un tas de phénomène de
société qui désespère aujourd'hui les
français parmi les plus modestes
alors on continue les gens du voyage par
exemple les gens du voyage lui a
confisqué leurs véhicules mais il faut
se rappeler des ordures et la fille les
problèmes des gens du voyage c'est que
une grande partie d'entre eux
s'installent sans droit ni titre sur des
progrès étaient d'autres huiles chez des
gens broyage comme les squatteurs nous
sommes dans un pays où il faut rétablir
l'autorité de l'état et on ne peut pas
venir s'installer sur la propriété
d'autrui sans droit ni titre se brancher
sur l'électricité public sans payer de
redevances se brancher sur les bouches à
incendie pour s'alimenter en eau potable
sans payer de redevances là où beaucoup
de françaises et de français font des
efforts considérables pour pouvoir faire
face à l'ensemble de ses responsabilités
et de ses charges
et lorsqu'on voit que pour la plupart
d'entre eux et c'est une réalité et vous
le savez thierry ardisson lien avec de
belles et grosses voitures dont jamais
personne ne s'est demandé l armée à
quelles conditions
je vais vous dire un truc les gens du
voyage n'ont pas de maison les
françaises achètent des papillons les
gens du menez achètent des mercedes
c'est moins cher la mercedez que le
pavillon mais simplement nous voulons
que comme les français ils soient soumis
aux mêmes vérifications et aux mêmes
règles dans les squatteurs les
squatteurs c'est les anciens gens du
voyage du coup ils ont barbou dit
christian estrosi visite les secrétaires
les ont pas droit d'occuper sans droit
ni titre
mais s'il avait un droit ailleurs dit il
serait pas squatters des locateurs je
savais qu'il y avait des milliers de
personnes aujourd'hui qui cherchent un
logement et les cas beaucoup d'entre eux
lorsque dans un office hlm par exemple
on leur affecte un appartement ils ne
peuvent l'occuper
parce qu'il ya souvent un squatteur et
ce squatteurs pour verser une
rémunération lui-même un caïd de
quartier qui fait son marché sur le dos
des braves gens ça c'est drôle on aurait
du che dans vos têtes ça vous voyez là
où on aurait dû s'arrêter ça de la
langue versa des caïds de quartier mais
ça dans les films
je ne sais pas s'il faut arrêter c'est
pas vrai traités il ya un caïd qui
contrôle les squats qui se trouve en
banlieue donc enfin ou dans l'est dans
les quartiers apparemment défavorisées
d'où on a vu ça moi j'y habite ou moins
fait une caricature dans tout cas assez
une caricature c'est déjà bien là j'ai
moi même j'ai moi même j'ai moi même
dans ma circonscription des quartiers
difficiles
je vis parmi ces braves gens et je vois
les difficultés
j'y ai ma permanence d'accord une
permanence autre point toujours la
fameuse loi sarkozy la prostitution
alors là c'est bien grave parce que je
pense balade en minijupe sur les
boulevards des maréchaux l'habite
tu fais gaffe estimé c'est une balade en
minijupe sur les boulevards des
maréchaux sont aussi d'ailleurs
tu peux être arrêté pour asus racoleuse
bon c'est vrai ou non
oui mais le racolage n'est pas un délit
nouveau dans les droits français
oui c'est un délit qui a toujours existé
simplement il ya quelques années on a
fait la différence entre racolage passif
et et et racolage actif est le résultat
des courses c'est qu'on additionnant
cette suppression du racolage passif par
rapport au racolage actif et en
modifiant les choses également dans la
loi de présomption d'innocence qui était
présenté par les socialistes en l'an
2000 on a démuni totalement les forces
de l'ordre pour pouvoir mener leur
action pour démanteler un certain nombre
de réseaux de prostitution
là encore il ne s'agit pas de s'attaquer
aux prostituées mais ce que vous savez
combien la france est menacée
aujourd'hui notamment par des réseaux de
prostitution de l'étranger qui viennent
des anciens pays de l'est qui viennent
d'afrique
est ce que vous savez qu'en région
parisienne 75% de la prostitution est
une prostitution étrangères près de 48%
en province les prostituées elles-mêmes
dahiri à moins d'un an de cela
défilé à lyon pour se plaindre de cette
invasion qui venaient de l'extérieur ça
génère une économie souterraine qui
avoisiner près de 167 millions de francs
l'année dernière de transfert entre la
france et les pays de l'est et surtout
ça conforte l'organisation d'une
criminalité organisée avec la branche
prostitution la branche trafic de drogue
la branche qui permet de blanchir
l'argent sale avec des opérations
immobilières douteuses
c'est bien évidemment en asséchant la
ressource que l'on atteindra le
proxénète et je veux préciser que
lorsque grâce à ces dispositions
on mettra en garde à vue une prostituée
étrangères aujourd'hui avec la
législation telle qu'elle existe on ne
peut pas la mettre en garde à vue plus
de quatre heures en quatre heures de
temps vous pouvez tout juste lui lui
fournir un interprète
et puis c'est terminé avec les nouvelles
dispositions vous pourrez la m 48 jours
à grand bruit mais 48 heures
faire mes courses fruits on a bien
compris détruire les gc on voit ici la
fonction d'albanie de bulgarie milieu de
tout ça on est assez d'accord tous mes
sens habituel française que vous dites
vouloir défendre la voyelle sont jamais
allés manifester cette semaine devant le
sénat s'est pas dites shenzhen mais sans
doute parce qu'elles ont mal compris